cerexbib king and district was once a
working-class residential area today
it's getting trendy we had for this
unimposing new building up under the
roof is a little oasis the elevator
takes us directly into the apartment
Erica Dixon and her partner have lived
in this 170 square meter condominium for
five years now the view over Zurich was
what sold him on it the couple did the
interior design of the loft apartment
themselves they wanted lots of colors
house where practically everything was
white for more than 20 years the floor
ceiling walls everything was just white
and here from the start I said I want
colorful walls and people don't really
notice it when they are here no one has
ever said oh there really is a lot of
color here or anything like that I think
everything has turned out harmoniously
they changed the floorplan completely
now the center of the apartment is the
open kitchen with the dining and living
area a 65 square metre space when the
weather is good it opens onto the
terrace the greenery here was designed
by the renowned Swiss architect Enzo and
Nia for this room it was important to be
able to extend the living space in the
summer and we realized that when we
opened the sliding window all the way
you're already basically outside when
you sit at this table fish the bedroom
has lots of color accents too a
free-standing wall separates the
sleeping area from the bath the wash
basin in the bathtub were designed by
the Swiss industrial designer Una's
Fitch Tyne putting a glass door on the
bathroom was a daring decision I know
I'm alone when I'm in there so why do I
need another door I think the effect is
nice with the mosaics that you can see
from the outside their furniture is a
colorful mixture of old heirlooms like
the 200 year old kitchen cupboard and
modern designer pieces
Eureka pixel knew how to spruce up these
somewhat elderly chairs this dual atiba
common agreement I know the chairs get
new clothes new slipcovers every once in
a while these chairs will soon be twenty
years old and I don't know how many
dresses they've already warned I changed
them again and again
I have summer fabrics and winter fabrics
that was good of my thing it's easy to
change them come on Jerry that was for
ending
Erica pixel was her art colorful too
she's a big fan of the American pop
artist Charles Ficino this picture
reminds her of her former job flight
attendants to be a flight attendant
flying to New York and other places of
course I saw a lot of the world MIT when
I started spending more time at home to
bring up the kids
I bought this painting by Ficino of New
York as a souvenir because in some
months I flew there four times but now
she's back at home in Switzerland and
what she cherishes most here are her
homes comfy atmosphere and expiry